reviens sur cette situation avec notre
invité Olivier Kempf bonjour et merci de
répondre à FRANCE 24 vous êtes directeur
du cabinet stratégique la vigie
chercheur associé à la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique bonjour à vous
d'abord quel est l'intérêt de la
manœuvre annoncée hier donc la
reconnaissance par Vladimir Poutine de
ces deux République autoproclamé
depuis un an depuis un mois pardon
visiblement qu'on reprenne les accords
de Minecraft qui pesait la question de
la discussion entre Kiev et la
république séparatiste ce que qui est
refusait il en a pris acte il a vu que
cette option ne fonctionnait pas et donc
il a il a poussé son avantage
c'est là où il en est sachant que ça
n'est finalement que la transcription
officielle d'une réalité qui durait
depuis 8 ans parce que ça fait 8 ans que
c'est République autoproclamé n'existe
que par le soutien russe donc au fond ça
change quoi puisque vous le disiez ça
fait 8 ans que ça dure que ces régions
sont aux mains des prorus
et bien ça change regarder la la la le
rapport de force et la crise politique
d'abord géopolitique mais aussi
économique à laquelle nous faisons face
puisque malgré tout c'est une violation
du droit international et de la
souveraineté
ukrainienne sur ses frontières en disant
que c'était c'est République sont
indépendantes il remet en cause
finalement l'intangibilité des
frontières qui est l'alpha et l'oméga de
de de l'ordre sécuritaire européen
depuis depuis la fin de la deuxième
guerre mondiale et puis c'est peut-être
une manière aussi de bloquer l'adhésion
de l'Ukraine à l'OTAN puisque
l'une des grandes règles de l'Alliance
c'est que les pays accueillis doivent
avoir résolu tous les différents qu'ils
ont avec la frontière et là c'est pas le
cas
alors certes mais c'était je dirais déjà
le cas depuis 2014 avec d'une part la
question de la Crimée et puis d'autre
part avec cette abcès si vous voulez de
des deux républiques de donuts qui est
Toulon ce qui ce qui change maintenant
si vous voulez c'est que au-delà de
l'Ukraine c'est
Vladimir Poutine veut visiblement aller
en avance c'est-à-dire que maintenant il
a toujours un certain nombre d'options
devant lui il est toujours entre
guillemets mettre du jeu je pense qu'il
est pas très impressionné par les
sanctions que l'on annonce d'abord il y
a déjà préparé ensuite il a accumulé
beaucoup de réserve l'augmentation du
prix du pétrole du gaz depuis 2 3 mois
lui a permis en plus
d'arrondir son Madeleine si je puis me
permettre et là il a un certain nombre
d'options d'abord des options militaires
parce que ce qui a été le plus frappant
finalement ça a été son discours hier
soir et tous ceux qui suivent un peu ces
questions là on va quand même été un peu
surpris de la tonalité de ce discours
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire dire que on a
l'habitude de décrire Vladimir Poutine
comme quelqu'un de froid de calculateur
de stratège hier on a senti beaucoup de
passion transparaître dans son discours
et et cette passion disait finalement
l'Ukraine est totalement russe et je
déni à ce pays l'existence et on se rend
bien que il est rentré dans une sorte de
marche en avant
si je puis dire les choses ainsi visant
à casser fracturé
le pays que l'Ukraine c'est c'est ça qui
est aujourd'hui en jeu et je pense que
dans la gamme d'option qu'il a il a à sa
tente de choses pour qu'on a les
République auto-programmé il peut dire
je veux la totalité des oblast
c'est-à-dire les circonscriptions
administratives celle de Donald's qui
est celle de louance qui sont pas
aujourd'hui complètement aux mains des
séparatistes il peut avancer le long de
la mère d'azooc jusqu'à Mario Paul il
peut aller et ça c'est finalement le
plus important jusqu'à Odessa ville où
il y a une grande minorité
qui est le port par lequel 60 %, 75 %
des approvisionnements Ukrainiens
maritimes
arrivent et qui à proximité de la
Transnistrie là encore haute conflit
gelée autre en gras et là vous avez
l'enjeu de la maîtrise de la mer Noire
ce qui explique d'ailleurs je me permets
une assise la réaction de récré
Erdogan qui a condamné ce qui s'est
passé parce qu'il voit bien que l'enjeu
finalement c'est toute la rive la
maîtrise de la rive de la mer Noire et
là
dislocation l'Ukraine vous parlez de
passion hier dans le discours de
Vladimir Poutine presque une obsession
même de l'Ukraine vous le disiez c'est
un pays stratégique
alors
si vous voulez c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est stratégique sur voilà
beaucoup de commentateurs disent que
c'est un pays qui doit être tampon comme
la Biélorussie la profondeur et cetera
et cetera bon probablement vrai ça
rentre probablement dans le calcul de
Vladimir Poutine ce qui était très
intéressant c'est que au-delà du calcul
stratégique je dirais froid peut-être un
peu cynique du stratégie du stratège
parce que lui il se protège il y avait
de la passion il y avait quelque chose
qui sortait finalement du du
du fond de je veux dire de son cœur
excusez-moi pour son âme enfin du
français tripes et on sentait que
écouter l'Ukraine c'est pas seulement
une profondeur stratégique c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est intimement lié à
la Russie c'est comme ça que que c'est
ce qu'il a exprimé je dis pas que c'est
juste je dis que c'est ce qu'il a
exprimé et ça ça surpris c'est assez
surprenant c'est-à-dire que
finalement on est plus seulement dans
l'ordre du calcul on est dans l'ordre de
l'affectif et ce qui rend les choses
probablement plus dangereuses que si
c'était juste du rapport de force ce qui
était finalement dans l'ordre du
calculat et donc du négociable vous
allez bien foutine qui a donc enterrer
hier les accords de paix les accords de
Minsk qui avait été
signé en 2014 il a reproché aux
Occidentaux de ne jamais pousser Kiev à
appliquer les accords de mine ce qui est
d'avoir seulement chercher à geler le
conflit est-ce qu'il y a une part de
vérité dans ce qu'il dit
je pense que quand la crise a commencé
il y a 5 ou 6 semaines
un certain nombre d'options étaient sur
la table on n'avait pas inéluctablement
à l'époque vers ce qui est en train de
se passer c'est-à-dire un raidissement
et puis une option qui est militaire et
peut-être demain une guerre il y a déjà
un conflit tu veux dire les soi-disant
conflit son meurtrier il y a eu 14000
morts dans l'Est l'Ukraine depuis 2000
2014 donc c'est c'est pas on peut avoir
une escalade
je crois que il y a 5 ou 6 semaines
peut-être peut-être surtout si les
Occidentaux très tôt on dit on va pas se
battre pour le prenne peut-être que il y
avait cette voie-là je n'en sais rien je
dis on va pas refaire l'histoire ce que
je constate c'est que depuis 2 semaines
c'était beaucoup moins praticable malgré
les efforts tardifs du du des
chancellerie occidentale et notamment du
président français la recherche de
probablement trop tardivement fort c'est
le constater et réussi mais il aurait
fallu commencer beaucoup plus tôt il y a
aussi la donc la question des sanctions
les Occidentaux qui parlent après ce
discours de sanction les États-Unis
restent sur une position assez
attentiste finalement ils sont
contraints bien de laisser Vladimir
Poutine agir comme il le veut alors je
crois qu'il y a il y a plusieurs choses
si vous voulez vous avez effectivement
si vous voulez ok on interdit le
commerce avec ces République c'est comme
si on interdisait si on voulait punir
quelqu'un qui est végan en lui disant tu
manges pas de viande il y a pas de
relation commerciale avec ses République
et le commerce qu'avec la Russie donc si
vous voulez c'est très anodin d'ailleurs
remarqué que au début il y a eu une
grande prudence le communiqué de
l'Élysée hier soir parler de de sanction
ciblées donc on fait attention et
pourquoi on fait attention à mon avis
c'est que on se dit qu'il faut regarder
un peu pour
parce qu'on s'attend à une escalade et
donc on va faire un premier un premier
paquet de sanctions mais on s'attend à
ce qui est une escalade à ce que
Vladimir Poutine ne s'arrête pas et
qu'il faille avoir des capacités de
réaction pour demain ou la semaine
prochaine quand les choses iront encore
plus mal et les Russes les Américains ne
sont pas fermés à un dialogue il y a
même une rencontre qui est prévu entre
sergueil lavrois et Anthony blinken
je crois jeudi une autre rencontre avec
Jean-Yves Le Drian c'est paradoxal non
c'est pas paradoxal parce que c'est à ça
que certes la diplomatie la diplomatie
ça sert pas à aller voir les gens qu'on
aime bien ça sert à aller voir le grand
méchant d'en face peu importe qu'il soit
réellement méchant ou pas il s'agit
c'est pas le débat celui que l'on
considère comme méchant comme son
adversaire que l'on considère comme
faisant des choses pas bien il faut
aller discuter par avec lui c'est ça le
rôle des diplomates donc il est
finalement normal que il y a toujours
ses actions diplomatiques est-ce à dire
quel mois de concluantes je n'en sais
rien c'est très aventureux il va falloir
écouter maintenant
que avec ce qu'il vient de se passer
hier soir il va formuler ou reformuler
des exigences et voir s'il y a des
choses qui sont accepta s'il y a des
choses que l'on peut admettre et si on
ne peut pas admettre qu'est-ce que l'on
peut mettre en face comme mesure de
rétorsion sur les sanctions c'est très
bien mais la Russie s'y est préparé on
parle beaucoup de
sortir la Russie du système de
compensation bancaire Swift mais il y a
déjà un système alternatif que les rues
sont mis en place et finalement ça ça
atteindra également les Européens et
dans une moindre mesure les Américains
donc les sanctions elles sont à double
jeu c'est ça un peu le problème dans
dans cette affaire c'est que le rapport
de force on a finalement pas grand chose
à mettre en face de Vladimir Poutine
merci en tout cas Olivier CAF de nous
avoir éclairé sur France 24 directeur du
cabinet stratégique la